Hi,
welcome to talks at Google and Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
We're here to,
uh,
I'm very proud to,
to welcome David Mccauley,
author of the,
the way things work.
This is a book that I think many of us have a lot of affection for that deeply
informative but also a lot of fun and whimsical.
Um,
my,
my son is in college now majoring in mechanical engineering and I like to think
that a part of that is actually,
you know,
our experience with the,
with the book when he was younger.
Um,
in any event,
uh,
David Macaulay's certainly someone who needs no more further introduction.
So without further ado,
please welcome David Mccauley.
Thank you.
I put together some slides.
Basically you did trace for you the,
a little bit of the history of the way things work.
It's a book that's been out now since 1988.
No one is more surprised than I am that it's still out and that it in fact has
been through a couple of revisions.
And,
um,
it makes me feel good because when we started,
I had no clue what was going to become of this book,
how it was going to be received.
At.
My biggest concern at the very beginning was the idea of working on a book,
the 400 pages.
It was all about machines.
It just seemed like an absurd task.
And for somebody with my attention span every of challenge.
So I was first asked to join the team and you can,
you know,
I mean,
teams,
um,
if you guys don't know teams,
I don't know who does.
Um,
but obviously this book was put together by a team.
I was the visual guy.
I was the,
uh,
the,
you know,
yeah.
Author in my own right when it comes to books about architecture and so on,
but not about technology.
Uh,
Neil hardly who wrote all the technical text for the book,
um,
became my teacher for,
you know,
four years.
Um,
and then again in [inaudible] 98 when we did the second review,
he would,
at first I went to London,
which is where they were putting this thing together and spent five days and uh,
did it four times to go for each of the four sections of the book.
And we went through every machine and Neil basically told me everything he knows
and I sketched while he was talking.
And this is the only way I knew whether or not I was actually learning anything,
whether I was really even listening to what he had to say.
Because after 10 minutes of technical,
well,
no,
I exaggerate.
After five minutes of technical talk,
I'm usually lost.
My eyes have glazed over and I,
so I need the pencil in my hand.
I need some tracing paper in front of me and they need to be in that process of
trying to interpret what I'm hearing so that I can then turn it over to,
uh,
to Neil and say,
is this,
this is where we're going?
Is this what we're talking about here?
And then I would come back and to the studio and attempt to reinterpret my
interpretation so that it could be used to present what I had learned and not
simply to record it,
but to present it in some sort of meaningful way.
Once you're looking at here is this was done before me.
This was done probably in 1982 or 1983 this was decays masterplan,
um,
in a very sketchy way of what they hope that the book would be things linked
together in various ways that would make it fun to turn the pages that would
ultimately though pass on information to the reader of the book about not only
how things work,
but more importantly perhaps how all the things work that we take for granted.
And that to me has always been the most important part of the book.
Why?
Which is why the book has always,
I think,
deserved to be updated because there's new stuff now that we've already started.
I mean,
not started,
we've already completely taken for granted.
I'm assuming that you guys are so far ahead of the curve,
but even those things that I'm thinking about,
uh,
seem sort of old fashioned and dated,
but no to most of us.
Um,
you know,
knowing how a a cell phone works at a touch screen works and that sort of stuff
is still or should be interesting to the average reader.
And I'm going for the average reader when it comes to visually presenting,
um,
this information.
So this was the diagram and uh,
this is one of the first image.
These are too early images I made and these were done for I think a Frankfurt
book fair or something like that.
They wanted to present the idea of this 400 page book about machines and get all
their European,
um,
cope publishers lined up and so on and so forth.
And the American publisher of course,
uh,
lined up,
um,
text,
little text heavy,
a little little doll.
But I declined the first time they asked me if I would be willing to do this job
because I honestly just didn't think that I could stay with it long enough to
get 400 pages worth of this stuff done without becoming seriously ill.
Um,
so,
so this was a,
this was again a,
an early mock up.
It looks like a Sears Roebuck catalog.
It looks like they've jammed every conceivable little contraption in there that
you can fit in there.
Um,
all that's left from that first slide was that little bit with the,
uh,
you know,
the sort of gears and the ferry,
the merry go round and at the fair,
that sort of stuff.
It's,
David is this enough space for this drawing?
So they were willing to shrink the text if my,
if I,
no,
my tents have to be higher.
But,
um,
nobody said can we get rid of some of this stuff?
Until I did,
but I didn't have any alternative plan.
So I,
um,
started sketching,
which is what I always do.
Um,
and I was trying to figure,
okay,
let's,
this thing is going to start with levers that seems fairly straight forward.
Let's,
let's just figure out how are we going to,
how do you present levers in a way that is,
um,
interesting that is engaging.
Um,
accuracy goes without saying,
but engaging is critical.
Um,
we could have,
we could have the,
you may know and some of you probably have seen maybe even own,
um,
the 19 was it 1980,
maybe a German edition of how things work.
I think it was called,
um,
you know,
before volumes and ultimately,
uh,
and,
and the,
all the illustrations were the two colors,
black and red,
I believe.
Um,
all line work,
uh,
mechanical drawings like you do in high school.
Um,
but detailed,
I mean incredibly detailed cross sections of machines and stuff like that.
Uh,
as if everybody who was interested in machines already knew how to read cross
sections and,
and those kinds of details.
Um,
so it did extremely well because I think for many of us,
we felt that these books would contain everything we would ever need to know
ever.
Um,
and,
and it's really kind of,
um,
reaffirming to be able to carry a volume like that around with you as you go
through life.
All the answers you would need about technology in that book.
But it wasn't the kind of book that I think would have gotten to those people
who weren't already kind of set up to understand it.
I mean,
in terms of getting the information from it.
So,
um,
so my approach was a little different.
I'm using my little Mac,
you know,
that little box,
whatever it was,
and the dot matrix printer and counting the letters to make sure I had,
you know,
enough in,
in a row and whatever it was for spacing.
Um,
I've created a obviously a stone age,
laundry laundromat with presses and things of that nature and it'll give me a
chance to play with the idea of levers,
levers,
and um,
also,
um,
introduced concepts.
So this is what I presented when we started talking and I kept going,
uh,
with this idea of how to organize,
asking this question,
okay,
how do we organize these levers?
And at the very bottom of this page,
you can see,
um,
the cave people never completely went away even though the laundromat didn't
make it.
Um,
and because I was drawing cave people,
I thought I would populate it with um,
other cave era things like in this case a mammoth.
And the mammoth of course stayed because I played with the mammoth.
I felt like I had a kindred spirit with the mammoth,
somebody equally victimized by technology and um,
but it,
but it sort of completely changed the way we started to think about the pages.
And this was going to be a book about machines that was going to be fun,
uh,
and yet taking seriously.
So sketching,
sketching,
finally trying to figure out how,
how will you work with a page?
Um,
and these are,
these are old,
these are on yellow tracing paper that if I touch it too many more times will
just disintegrate.
But it got the job done.
This is one of the original pieces of art based on those sketches obviously.
And it was from those,
um,
those,
those sketches.
And from that sense of going back as far in history as possible to introduce the
simplest of machines that I came up with,
this idea of the inventors notebook,
the inventors notebook allowed me to sort of suggest this personality who was
kind of interested in how things work,
but inevitably got it slightly backwards.
And because it was clearly a page that was not you,
you know,
hard and co hardened dried fast,
uh,
facts and all that sort of stuff.
It was a playful intro.
Um,
I could get away with that,
but of course I,
if I was going to say things backwards or misunderstand them,
it had to be to set up the real information that would appear at the bottom of
the page.
So,
so mammoths,
uh,
with three different kinds of levers,
first,
second and third class and your basic little diagrams at the bottom.
But the fun stuff is up top.
And the story.
I,
the only thing I wrote in this book were the little stories about the mammoth
and um,
at his or her adventures,
I did not have to write any of the technical stuff.
I just had to understand it.
So then we can move from mammoths to levers while almost from mammoths,
not quite leaving them behind to other devices that illustrate the use of
levers.
The grand piano.
At the bottom of this illustration,
uh,
there used to be in the first edition and I believe also in the second edition.
In fact,
I know I'm a mechanical typewriter and other nice visual example of levers at
work.
Um,
for this new addition,
we've taken out the mechanical typewriter and we've taken out a few other things
in order to free up some space for the new devices,
the new machines and so on.
So they,
a foot pedal was a new addition.
Uh,
so,
um,
warm gears,
you never know,
um,
whether an idea is actually worth holding onto or not,
but it doesn't stop me from at least putting it on paper.
Okay.
I'm looking to have some real fun here with gears,
gears and belts,
that sort of thing.
Waving hand,
huge scale,
Trojan,
horse sized,
waving hand.
Um,
this is just sitting at the drawing board with a pat of tracing paper and just
putting down whatever popped into my mind,
um,
with one or two words in my head,
the kind of guide,
the thought back to that first sketch,
but now perhaps a more elaborate version of the fairground and the gears,
um,
which got sort of compressed and change the gears of disappeared for a moment as
we're just looking at belts here and wheels trying to figure out how to really
have fun with the visual parts of the visual imagery,
but also make sure that the verbal chunks are from a compositional point of view
in an appropriate place to not inhibit the flow across the spread.
I'm always trying to figure out how to make these compositions work so that the,
the reader is led in some sort of meaningful and hopefully useful way across the
pages.
An early,
um,
full color version.
Oh,
full color.
That's another thing I should mention.
Uh,
the original book,
at 400 pages was um,
half full color and half to color alternating spreads.
Reason being to keep the price down.
They were worried about the cost of a 400 page book.
Um,
so we did half of it in two color.
This is one of the two colors,
but it's just really nasty.
This is a very nasty spread.
It was nasty then.
It's a nasty now.
So I reworked it and um,
now we're looking at the color that was actually reproduced in the book back in
88 and the gears now have become larger and clearer.
They weren't lost,
you know,
amid all that other stuff in the earlier on in the earlier spread.
But still it's fun and the little elements of play,
I hope reward those,
particularly those younger readers who come back and look at the book a second
time and the third time and a fourth time.
And this is not,
I hope,
a one read book.
Um,
I,
I hope and it's the only reason I could use to sort of justify the silliness of
parts of it.
It's a book that has to welcome a multi-varied approach,
but if you just want to get in there and get the information that also has to be
clear,
this is the revised,
the newly revised spread,
uh,
from the way things work now.
And I went back in and recolored all of the art that was done in two color back
in 88.
That was my,
that was kind of my,
the deal,
if I was going to have to go back into this book and Redo all this stuff,
I at least wanted a chance to change once.
And for all those two callers pieces,
not because they're just two color,
but because in many cases,
um,
they weren't as clear as they could be when it came to reading the information.
So here was a chance to make sure the line work held up and um,
and,
and it was done digitally.
I mean,
I,
I sat there with my,
have a very sophisticated
computer system.
I'm still using Photoshop elements.
So,
which came with my scanner.
I have nothing to do with the cloud.
I have no idea what they've been up to.
They probably been up to great stuff.
Here I am using stone age digital technology,
um,
to take out the color from a two color drawing without killing the lines and
then putting color back in and trying to hold on to some sense of texture that
will match the full color pieces that were leaving as they were.
Um,
I did not want it to look like a book that had been messed with and wanted it to
look like a new book that was sort of consistent from beginning to end.
And I think the reproduction of it was,
has been so terrific that,
um,
that it all worked.
These were two color in the original book.
They're now clear to read the gears.
Um,
as you can see on the right hand side,
um,
we're really lost.
It got muddy and dark and so now you can actually see where the different gears,
um,
are and how they relate to each other.
There a two color as a four color,
um,
minor changes.
Now I didn't want it sort of go crazy with the color I did in a couple of spots,
but I didn't generally speaking,
want to go crazy with it because one of the limitations forced upon me by the
two color for color alterations wasn't,
the color stuff couldn't be crazier.
It would've created a real,
um,
disruption.
Um,
as you turn the page to two color would've looked really don't and dead next to
a really vibrant to color spread.
So the color was muted back then to match the two color limitations.
And this time I was making new color,
but it had to,
it was muted now by the old color.
Um,
one of Neil's,
uh,
when he got frustrated with me,
he would make these,
these drawings,
these diagrams.
So we wanted to do the engine in a and m show me everything that he felt should
be in it.
And,
and then we would talk about what it does and so on and so forth.
And my job was then to okay interpret.
And,
um,
so it just a series of sketches,
what point of view,
where are we when we look at this engine,
we need to be in the best place from which to see the bulk of the information
clearly and begin to understand how it all works together.
You can't necessarily,
um,
for instance take a photograph of an engine that,
will be the most ideal spot.
You're,
you're going to sacrifice things.
I can,
as an illustrator,
I can move things around a little bit.
I can distort slightly.
So these,
these,
some sketches are kind of a glimpse into the process.
These are all just pieces of tracing paper.
Um,
and I'm playing with point of view.
I want this thing to be dramatic.
It's got to be one of the most influential machines,
um,
certainly ever made in my lifetime.
And uh,
so it needed to,
it,
it could afford to have some power.
So you chain,
you look up at this thing,
you sort of look up in wonder at it perhaps.
Um,
now redraw.
It was maybe things were off,
maybe the um,
you know,
various pieces of the cracks were off or out of alignment or something like
that.
So you're always sketching over sketching over sketching.
I draw on paper all the time,
even though I use elements,
um,
maybe it's elements six,
I can't remember.
Uh,
but the drawings have to be on paper because it just feels right.
I have tried,
um,
I work obviously on a tablet when I'm putting the color in a and I've gotten
used to it,
but I can't say it gives me pleasure to move that stylists over the,
my little bamboo tablet.
Let me,
I told you a stone age,
um,
and I've entertained the notion of trying to go to a real screen,
you know,
and draw on it and,
and all that sort of stuff.
That's good.
It sounds like too much work.
Anyway,
those are the first version.
Full color version,
very muted.
And um,
in fact,
at the end I didn't like it.
So I,
I,
I reworked it,
move things around a bit.
This is the new one.
This is the one that,
you know from the first edition of the book and that has been reproduced again
in the latest edition of the book.
The angels are still there.
Um,
you need angels.
If you want to suggest any kind of,
um,
mythical importance,
any kind of,
um,
spiritual impact from these devices than angels.
And they're,
you know,
they're the low bidders,
so they got the job.
Uh,
here's the,
um,
harvester,
the combine harvester.
This was a two color image in the first book.
This is,
believe it or not,
it's a four color piece of art,
but it's much clearer.
It's so much easier to read now the flow of wheat and all the stuff,
um,
that gets thrown away and the way it's stored and,
and whatnot.
Uh,
the sewing machine was fun,
super scale,
changing the scale of something I always find amusing.
Um,
it can make something look more important.
It could make it look more intimidating,
but it can also make it look clear because you can see,
um,
you know,
see the detail better if you blow it up.
And also as an illustrator,
you're,
you're an editor.
The whole time you're also deciding what to leave in and what to get rid of,
what's really important here and what can stay.
So that's,
um,
I often think that it may be one of the most important jobs of an illustrator is
to serve as editor and decide what goes in.
You have to know what you're trying to say.
And if you do know what you're trying to say,
it's easy to see those things that are simply going to disrupt it or get in the
way.
It might look impressive.
You might really want to draw it,
but it might not actually serve the purpose of the end of the day of um,
communicating clearly.
Drone obviously is not from an older edition.
That's a new addition.
Um,
and the,
um,
you know,
you don't know who's,
uh,
who's a little wing that is sticking out from the Brownstone Church,
until you look at the screen of the little handheld controller.
Um,
so anyway you tell a little story in there and um,
those are the things I'm talking about when I say those things that you go back
to this,
maybe you don't even see it the first time.
Maybe you don't even see it the third time.
Maybe you don't see it until you're lucky enough to be sitting there with a kid
and your book or his or her book open and they pointed out to you.
I would recommend that we can't sell the books with kids.
You have to get your own.
But the book has those things in it.
Um,
this is a model for,
this is one of those funny compositions,
um,
where a lot of things got kind of moved over into the left hand page.
The text actually in this on the left hand page spread actually simplifies the
open spaces here just seem kind of um,
you know,
at a loss for some sort of purpose.
The fact is though they contained the chunks of text which stops that whole
thing from just kind of floating around in a messy way.
But what we wanted was room for the airport scanner on the,
uh,
on the right hand page.
And so why did I choose,
um,
the white rabbit from Alice in wonderland?
Because I wanted the watch.
I wanted the watch to show up on the screen in the lower right hand corner.
Sometimes the logic seems a little bit,
um,
unusual,
uh,
and stretched.
But nevertheless,
that's why we've got a rabbit here,
uh,
about to put his paws up and,
and be looked at off into space.
Uh,
yeah,
Moon landers on Mars Rovers and things of that nature.
Now this is one of the instances.
This is a double.
There's a,
um,
two color spread from the original and uh,
but it's hard to see the heat and the furnace.
Um,
it's hard to see that the,
the uh,
the heat in the Bessemer
contraption.
Um,
so I did it again,
new color for color,
so to call it a four color.
And in this case,
I think you've got a fighting chance of telling that it's hot and seeing where
it's hot and we're at Kohl's and so on.
So that was worth going to.
This is the old dot matrix printer.
The point of view,
I,
the perspective you use sometimes can give things a,
an extra dignity.
Uh,
you know,
so a real boldness.
This is something from Star Trek.
Uh,
it's probably filled with lots of little people,
but for me it's just the dot matrix printer.
Um,
one of my favorite compositions that sort of following the movement of the tape
through a video recorder.
The video recorder is gone from the new edition has to be replaced.
And as is the sound,
the sound tape recording,
uh,
method.
Uh,
so,
but you can see this gives you a couple of clues to is how I work.
There are pieces of paper stuck over paper with scotch tape that have changed
colors.
Uh,
magic tape is my preferred tape.
So I have elements,
magic tape,
my own photocopier,
and that's pretty much it.
One flat surface that's generally speaking clear so that I can draw on it
whenever I feel like I need to.
Or there's a deadline approaching
light bulbs,
the first spread and the light bulb.
Um,
Ada used to be just that light bulb in the lower left hand corner.
Not The candle but the light bulb.
Now it's dead.
Electricity has been turned off and we looking at the replacements and a sense
of where we're going.
And I,
I sort of did amp up the color a little bit here,
the video recorder
and step by step sort of process of reading the frames and how it focuses and a
projector,
a video projector and a three d projector.
They think the thing that I loved about the um,
the video projector,
those little things at the bottom,
those tiny little mirrors,
um,
a grid of mirrors that all move in,
you know,
in a slightly different way.
Just enough to send the light off at the wrong in the wrong direction if you
don't want it or channel in the right direction if you do one.
I love those things because they seem so practical.
It's just a sensible solution.
The trick is to get like 10,000 little mirrors on a,
on something the size of the gum that I just smaller than the gum I spit out
and then recording digitally,
I'm sound and light breaking the uh,
this information down,
simplifying it to,
uh,
work with the text and the in the most sort of in the clearest way possible.
Uh,
these are,
these are looser spreads in in some ways a more open,
more spacious spreads then we're in the first edition.
So,
um,
I don't know whether that's because the information was becoming more
technically complex and I didn't want to sort of over over over do it three d
printer almost self explanatory.
But nevertheless we decided to put it in the book because it has become a more
familiar item in schools and even in homes and offices and workplaces.
The hybrid
almost didn't do this happened to be at a soccer game.
Um,
when my son was playing and,
um,
I was talking to the father of another player on the team and I was telling him
about the book I was working on and the revisions to the way things work.
And he said,
well,
so you're going to do the hybrid.
And you know,
that probably he probably saw the blood drained from my face when I realize
we're halfway through these illustrations and none of us thought about the
hybrid,
the hybrid car.
And the car had been such a major part of the book for the first two editions
anyway,
caught it at the last minute,
thanked him profusely,
storage devices.
This is a problem.
Um,
for me,
I mean,
how much can I do here to get this idea?
I'm,
all I can really do is be the x ray eyes looking at a UBS,
uh,
you know,
flashdrive and things like that.
USB,
UBS,
a flashdrive and um,
those devices,
it's just little boxes on a green bed.
And,
uh,
I think that if there's to be another version of this,
um,
of this book,
first of all,
I probably won't do it.
But secondly,
I think it's going to have to be really huge because I want you,
I mean,
I'd like to get inside the chip and you know,
to draw,
but to draw even a little chip and draw it big enough so you can just see how
complicated it is.
We do talk about gates and all that sort of stuff,
but um,
I think that may be the next step,
really large,
really large book.
And I,
I mean the idea of making it another book,
I'm always appeals to me over it moving to another medium,
even though that may be kind of impractical because I love the idea of rewarding
that sort of quietness of confronting the reader with all this technology,
but in a way that so friendly,
they are completely in control of what's it,
they can't press the wrong button and suddenly find themselves looking at
something that has nothing to do with it.
We're being distracted by ads.
The great thing about books is we have no ad space in this book at all.
Um,
there are lots of cross references.
You could be sent back to different pages.
That's,
that's true.
That's in there.
But,
um,
the whole thing though is basically your call and,
and you can obviously absorb this stuff at a rate that feels right for you.
Okay.
30 minutes is up.
It is now time for me to open the floor to questions about anything that can
have to do with this book.
It can have to do with [inaudible].
Just my question is what is the drawing that is just kind of inspired you the
most?
Or what drawing did you make that was just like,
you can't believe you even explained it well
from this book?
Uh,
sure,
sure.
That's what I was a little noncommittal.
Um,
I mean what I,
the reason I was asking,
I was hoping you were going to give me a way out.
I think the,
um,
there isn't one that honestly comes to mind as sort of like one boy.
I really nailed it.
I can tell you one that I did not nail and that is the automatic transmission of
the car.
It was the very last drawing I did in,
um,
in 88,
87.
I mean,
literally it was April of Ada.
The book was going to press and I had still not dumb the
automatic transmission of the car.
I drew it.
I still can't tell you how it works,
but nobody's brought it up.
So I must've been working with,
you know,
I was working with a good team who would have spotted anything,
but I did not.
That's the one drawing where I don't feel I absorbed the information in the way
I like to.
Um,
but I would go back to a book like cathedral and say that those are the drawings
that in a way,
um,
make me feel,
uh,
proud to have done them because they come there.
The end result of really getting to know how you pile one stone on top of
another,
which you can tell from my tongue in cheek,
uh,
comments about the digital stuff I use,
I feel much more comfortable with.
It can be a piece of limestone and we'll just put another piece of limestone on
top of it until we're done.
And,
but then it looks fantastic and then it stands for 800 years,
you know?
Anyway,
go ahead.
Yeah.
Curious how this became your book.
You know,
your name is
prominent on the cover and you say you work with a team and I vow and when did
that happen?
That my name,
because my name is on the front of this book because of the American market.
That was a decision made by the publisher and it has been a s a s a source of
discomfort from the very beginning,
from the very first time it happened.
But when,
when Houghton Mifflin,
uh,
picked up the book in the U S and I only did it cause Holton was my publisher,
I only did it,
um,
with decay on the condition that [inaudible] would do the American,
the American version.
So,
um,
but what happens is then people don't know Neil [inaudible] name in this
country,
didn't know his name.
Um,
they knew me,
so it was simply easier.
I would imagine that the pressure came from the sales department basically,
who don't really want to have to explain things and they just want to,
okay,
this has got Macaulay's names on top.
This must be good by many.
Um,
what else would make sense?
So anyway,
whenever I,
whenever I go,
I talk about the team.
I always mentioned Neil and get Neil and Neil's no longer with us.
Christopher Davis is no longer with us.
He was one of the key guys for getting this idea developed.
Um,
but I'm the,
I'm the shell,
you know,
it's as simple as that,
but I can draw.
Yes.
You've been talking an awful lot about your background in low tech,
specifically well illustrating and explaining some extremely high tech things.
I'm curious as to whether there were any,
uh,
any high tech
technologies that you decided to leave out.
Again,
that was a,
that was a team decision.
Um,
and what I can remember,
they would have been more,
I mean,
maybe too technical,
maybe too esoteric,
um,
for,
uh,
for the audience we were after I,
the whole idea from the beginning was kind of to open people's eyes to the basic
information behind how things work.
Whether it's a mechanical things or electrical things,
digital things,
get the basics across,
not try to anticipate what the next machine would be or even do the most
sophisticated versions of those machines,
but pick those things that would lend themselves to this kind of old fashioned
kind of interpretation.
So it is all about,
it's about stimulating curiosity,
but it's also about,
um,
being reassuring that it is possible on some level to understand this stuff
unless it's the automatic transmission.
Yes.
Uh,
first I wanna thank you.
Um,
I grew up a flipping through this book before I could even read it and I think
that's a big part of why I'm here today.
Um,
you mentioned that,
um,
you're trying to create these drawings so that there's simple enough for
children to understand and I think they are.
Um,
but having tried to explain things,
I know that that's actually incredibly difficult and requires a very deep
understanding of these.
And I was wondering if you could go into your process of like how you and your
team figure out the internals before you create these drawings.
Well,
sure.
Um,
I mean it's literally kneel largely and I,
um,
and maybe David Bernie locked in a room,
with whatever reference material Neil has brought to the table and we start
like,
what is this thing?
Um,
what does it do?
What's the most important thing about it?
And how
do certain hat,
what aspects of this machine and the way it works or similar shouldn't machines
we might already have,
um,
introduced elsewhere in the book.
It was,
it was always also about linking things and looking for surprising connections
between,
between things in that the machines would do completely different,
um,
jobs.
And yet the technology behind them,
um,
would be very similar or there would be a strong overlaps.
And it was just,
you know,
it literally back and forth.
Um,
okay,
let's just,
we go through this and I'm drawing it and Neil is explaining it and,
um,
I'm being corrected or I'm,
and I'm trying to think a little bit even then probably about those things that
seem exciting to me from what I've just heard.
And how could I,
you know,
can we,
can I make this image in such a way that it will also,
um,
promote that,
that potential bit of excitement so that it enhances the engagement part of the
job of,
of making these illustrations,
getting the information right as one thing,
but engaging the audience is critical.
So,
um,
but that was the process.
It wasn't magic and we just stayed there until we were done and came out at the
end of the day exhausted.
Um,
and did it until we had done 400 pages worth.
Yeah.
So complete change of pace.
Um,
is it okay if I confess that I have a soft spot for motel of the mysteries and
spent a good long time reading shortcut over and over to my children?
Yes,
it is actually his,
it's been,
please feel free.
Don't stop.
Don't stop there.
But anyway,
um,
those have things somewhat,
I mean the playfulness is certainly present here,
but these feel like very different books from this.
And I'm wondering if you could just comment a little bit on this end from
cathedral and from some of those others.
It seems like a very wide range of work.
And,
um,
cathedral was the first of four or five books on architecture.
Um,
and I realized once I had done number five,
which happened to be castle,
which is a very popular,
but I almost couldn't get through it because there was nothing to learn.
Um,
nothing new to learn as an illustrator.
As a designer.
I was basically taking the formula that I had established with cathedral kind of
proven,
worked in city and impairment and plugging in new information,
slightly new information,
uh,
in order to end up with a castle on a hill.
Um,
I just couldn't imagine doing another of those books and that's when I kind of
lost it slightly and said I want to do something completely different.
Um,
and I had been traveling,
I'm giving talks at elementary schools and so on.
And most of the elementary schools I was going toward the high schools,
whatever.
Um,
these are,
uh,
school districts that don't have huge budgets for fine hotels.
And so,
uh,
authors and illustrators who pass through town get put in these,
um,
whatever's available.
So I would walk into these motels,
you know,
like one after another in different parts of the country.
And I would start to notice these similar things like,
you know,
the,
uh,
the plastic shower curtain still held up,
but by only three rings,
um,
those stainless steel or,
or chrome plated something or other steel loops are hoops that stick out of the
wall that they,
um,
they wad the towels up under pressure and they stick them in so that if you pull
it out without paying attention,
now he can be damaged by that.
Like just like a car suddenly stopping.
Um,
but there were these crazy things.
There was,
um,
there was a light bulb fused to the plastic shade over the formica table,
in front of the window that looked down on the green astroturf covering around
the pool.
There was the pool.
Um,
and I began to realize that anybody coming from another place,
I didn't,
another time would begin to wonder if these weren't some kind of,
if there was more,
it wasn't more to it that something symbolic going on here.
So that's when I did motel.
I just wanted to play,
I wanted to not do architecture,
but as you know,
I drew it in a very kind of painstakingly old fashioned,
serious way,
completely confusing the times they look like images that might have been made
when Howard Carter was actually um,
you know,
looking at Tooton Commons,
a tomb as opposed to a story set 2000 years from now.
So it was completely mixed up,
but I was having fun.
I was playing.
The irony is that book is also still in print and fall.
It has its own following and so on and so forth.
So that book,
the way things work and the earlier architecture books continue to sort of move
along.
Um,
shortcut again was just a book to have some fun and play with full color and,
and that sort of thing.
So I need a break.
Those are vacation books for me in a way.
Yeah.
The question was are they going to be more,
but here,
let me,
let me ask this because I'm just following up on that.
I'm also up here to praise you for the whimsy.
In these books.
I,
uh,
I come from a lineage of engineers and architects and drafts people and
illustrators.
And so we had,
you know,
stacked high castle and pyramid and Citi and so forth at home.
But the one that,
you know,
uh,
I as a young reader was of course most drawn to is great moments in
architecture.
Um,
which I,
I just,
I,
I love and I wish I could find my original copy of it.
Um,
but I think that that,
that whimsy is so important because it,
it enhances attention and attention being that prerequisite for understanding.
And it seems like this whole AUV is about the way that knowing and understanding
and teaching and showing her all related.
Early on in the,
in the talk you said,
oh,
I didn't,
I didn't write any of the technical words that just had an understand them.
But I feel like that's the higher bar people,
people write about technical things all the time,
but fewer people understand them.
Um,
so I wanted to thank you for that.
And likewise,
I'll reiterate if there are any more vacation books coming were eagerly
anticipated.
I,
um,
I don't know.
I don't know,
but I'm,
I was going to pick on something you said about,
uh,
I mean it's really,
you could call this book the way I work,
the way Mccauley works because it really is,
you know,
from a visual,
a visual point of view,
it really is that revelation.
This is how I work.
This is how I think.
I fortunately have great backup and,
um,
and,
and all this terrific information that makes,
you know,
the clear and well written and all that sort of stuff.
And,
you know,
good guidance from an editorial perspective.
But basically it's me playing,
um,
in a way that's not totally dissimilar from,
from shortcut or great moments in architecture.
Yup.
So you mentioned when you started talking about all of this,
that your goal was to,
to kind of open people's eyes to all of the things that they took for granted in
the world around them.
And so I'm really curious how the team that you were working with decided,
what were the things that people take for granted the world around them?
You know,
were,
were people looking around and just inspired by what they saw or did you talk
with your families,
or how,
how was the decision made to what,
what should go into the 400 pages?
It was,
I think mostly,
um,
just based on experience,
based on what we saw.
Um,
I mean the hybrid,
as I said,
barely made it in just the luck of the draw.
Um,
but I just,
you know,
you're sitting around and you're,
you're at the table and you're having this conversation and you throw things out
and they're the most obvious things.
Um,
when you know,
after the fact they,
the most obvious things,
there's nothing in there that's um,
that would surprise you.
They may be things that should be there.
And they said it's your surprise that they're not.
But I,
I don't think there's too much of that either.
Uh,
it's,
it was very,
it was very common sense driven.
Those,
no,
um,
you know,
what are people doing?
And everybody's walking around like this,
you know,
so let's do that.
And people are doing this a lot and let's do some of that.
Um,
so I get to discover things like e ink who knew e ink,
you know,
those little clear balls filled with,
um,
charged particles.
Some are white and some are black.
And how'd they get them in there?
That's what I want to know.
And I couldn't find that out.
I couldn't figure it out.
Nobody could tell me or would,
um,
I don't know whether that's,
uh,
you know,
proprietary information or not.
But if anybody here knows how you get charged black and white particles in a
clear steer in liquid and liquid in a clear sphere,
that's about the diameter of a human hair.
Um,
let me know before I get,
you know,
I'm on my way out.
Just tell me.
Um,
I just,
I can only envision little people,
really small people,
that tiny little hands.
So,
um,
but so there's nothing magic to the,
to the choice,
honestly and no is no.
Um,
I was going to say there's,
there's no sort of committee,
uh,
that we don't try things in front of an audience versus say,
okay,
let's include that.
I mean,
you got a few tired people sitting around a table with lists of possibilities
and just,
I think the trick is to just look around you.
It would have been worse had we sort of over-thought that because then you run
into the cha,
the possibility of including things that really aren't that fun and certainly
aren't taken for granted.
It's the stuff that we,
ourselves no longer see.
We just reached for it.
We know where it is,
we know how to operate it.
We also know that when it dies,
you throw it away and you just get another one.
So that's it.
Common sense and just shared conversation,
calling on the eating thing.
Uh,
it seems like your technique is great for mechanical things,
things that move and structural things,
but do you find that with more abstracts,
digital things that don't move,
is it more difficult to impossible.
Amen.
It's not more difficult.
It's almost,
I mean,
just dealing with electricity,
you know,
you're forced to,
um,
yeah.
What are your choices?
You can do ready kilowatt with sneakers.
Um,
and that worked for the electric company,
I guess in the electric companies back in the 60s.
Um,
the 1960s.
Uh,
and there are arrows suggesting direction.
I mean I hate it when I'm basically forced up against arrows.
Um,
as the only way out metaphor becomes too,
too risky because while it's fun to play with,
it can become far more complicated than the thing you're trying to get across.
Um,
you,
you certainly do end up promoting the notion that this is a complex thing in
your metaphor,
but it may not make the information that,
that you need to communicate any clearer.
So,
um,
it is more difficult and the harder it is to see what's going on.
I love mechanical things as a drawing in the new book of the,
um,
the video game player controller.
Um,
and my favorite part of it is a little piece under your thumbs,
that little universal joint thing that allows your thumbs to do all that amazing
stuff.
I,
that's one of the,
the machines in which I was able to use the real thing because I have a now 17
year old son,
but he's,
he was younger a little while ago,
and,
um,
he's his W it's the order in which I like it actually.
Uh,
he,
um,
you know,
he has,
he has been known to have a little bit of a temper when he's playing these games
and he's losing.
Um,
and,
and we keep telling him it's not that important.
It's just the,
yeah.
So he has this bag of half damaged,
half destroyed controllers that he's sort of been in the corner of his room
forever.
So when I did research,
I just went up to Sanders Jose,
and I said,
you mind if I have one of those controllers that pick 'em all,
um,
and,
and looking at that thing and taking it apart.
And I drew it and I thought I understood it the first time I drove,
I drove it again and I still didn't get it right.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's the,
it's not just the way these things move and the way they're sort of hinge than
one,
but it's the way the material works to allow something to move in one direction.
So it,
it,
it is wonderfully complicated but visually rewarding because at the end of it
you kind of have a sense of,
oh,
I see,
I get it.
I understand how the pieces go together.
I understand how it works.
Those are very satisfying moments.
And whereas the rest of it is that Greenfield with all the little gray boxes and
lots of little lines,
not easy,
not as easy to see as they used to be.
Um,
a little blobs of silver.
A city basically does the city.
And then there were these two big chunky stone age things on the side of the
wonderful,
uh,
range of,
technical stuff.
We still have to appeal to the farm and work with the foam even though this
stuff doesn't care about the fum so much.
But these do,
and that's kind of Nice.
And I think that's why I am drawing still to those,
to those pieces of the larger contraption.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I just also wanted to thank you for your books.
Uh,
I didn't get to be nearly as many of them at some of these people when I was a
kid because my brother was fiercely protected,
but his copies,
I literally had to sneak into his room.
And so it's not until I've been a dad where I have people in my family to give
me an excuse to go until the children's section,
but I'm still bigger than them and can fight them off that I've gotten to
actually catch up.
Uh,
underground was just a couple of years ago they found me a real owner of the
children's section when my wife wanted to leave.
It was like,
where is dad?
And it turns out he was,
I was over there.
I'm good.
Thanks.
And I'm curious if there's anything that you've been either now or in the past
it really wanted to explain.
It really ate away at Hsu,
but it took a long time or a particular insight before you really felt like,
you know,
something that just sat there for a while,
not just for a week or two,
but maybe a year or two.
And you really finally broke through and
you just described the motivation behind doing the way we work and work on the
human body.
I was 55 and I knew nothing basically about how I work,
not see,
I mean most,
most crudely fundamental stuff.
Um,
and I thought,
I've got to,
I've got to figure this out.
And so I know,
you know,
to justify it.
Um,
this what turned out to be a six or seven year education,
um,
that is to say,
to pay for it,
I had to make a book.
Uh,
it's the hardest thing I've ever done.
Um,
I think I made some progress.
You know,
I,
um,
I knew I had a pancreas for instance.
I had no idea where it was.
I knew it wasn't far,
but I didn't,
I couldn't have told you and I couldn't have told you what it did,
why it was important.
And so on,
having watched one removed during a,
you know,
a stint at a,
in an emergency room,
uh,
none of them are.
I'm an operating room.
Um,
I have a very strong memory of,
of,
um,
of this thing now and where it was because I saw the a cavity inflated with air,
uh,
so that they could get in there and work around and all that sort of stuff.
Watching it on the monitor,
seeing the person in front of me.
Um,
that was the one where I was driven by guilt as much as anything,
not just curiosity,
but guilt and curiosity,
what is going on inside me.
And uh,
the funny thing about that day and the Orr was,
um,
I got there,
I like everybody does at six in the morning and you put on the scrubs and the
whole thing.
And I'm leaning up against the wall because the table is only like about there.
So I'm back as far against the wall as I can.
And after about two hours of this surgery and really getting hungry and it just
seemed odd,
but I was maybe a little cold in there and not cold but cool.
So that may have had something to do with it.
But then I realized I'm getting hungry because it smells like we're at a
barbecue.
Cauterizing anyone.
So,
um,
so the,
it'd be the,
and it just filled the air with this really pleasant in a really gruesome
setting.
So anyway,
I'm learning all the time and seeing connections and relationships between
things that,
um,
I don't normally reveal.
But anyway,
that was,
that was the book.
Um,
in terms of future stuff,
there's a lot of stuff I kind of liked to know about.
Um,
there wasn't one at the top of the list.
I'm finishing up a book now on the Sse United States,
the fastest steam ship in the world.
And it's the one that brought us,
my family and I to this country in 1957 from South Hampton,
there was a 10 year old kid and I remember I'd never been so bored in my life.
I'm on this amazing thing,
fastest,
um,
spectacular navy built for the navy as well as for commercial use.
And,
um,
what I remember best is going to the movies because they were free as a kid
coming from the north of England,
that was a huge deal.
Um,
I went to the same movie three times a day for five days,
um,
and I spent the rest of my time on deck looking for the Empire State building,
which I was convinced I would be able to see
as we passed the Ireland because it was really big.
Really.
So anyway,
I'm finishing that now and then I really do have to entertain what you're,
you know,
sort of the idea that you're talking about what's next,
what is it that I think I can devote some time to and um,
you know,
learn and,
and so on.
Thank you.
Go ahead,
David,
who you just spoke to mentioned underground that I wanted to also mention that
as one of your books had the most impact on me.
It actually gave me a physical sense of vertigo while reading it.
So well done.
Good.
Thanks.
Um,
and I wondered whether you thought about why you use drawing as a medium to
communicate ideas to other people,
but whether you've thought about talking about drawing itself,
teaching people how to draw or just talking about you're the one way that use
your own way that you see drawing.
Um,
for me it's one of the most satisfying things I can,
I can do,
but it's really about connecting with the world around you.
Drawing for me,
it's not,
I don't draw draw from,
um,
sort of invent something and then start drawing it.
To me,
that's sort of doodling.
Um,
I really liked to draw something,
but something that I have to dismantle,
even if I can't actually physically take it apart,
I can dismantle it on the paper.
I can dismantle it while I'm drawing.
And the use of a pencil or the fountain pen on tracing paper is the most,
um,
it,
it was such a gentle relationship.
I mean there's,
it's so soothing.
It's so,
it's wonderful to do it.
Um,
and there's no preciousness.
I'm not thinking of composition when I start drawing.
I'm not thinking of how to arrange these things.
I'm simply letting this,
completing this process of taking things in,
interpreting them in my brain,
sending it down to my hand,
try and get,
looking at that and seeing if that connects with what began the process and just
this,
the cycle,
um,
is to me the great pleasure of,
of drawing,
whether I'm recording outside,
enjoying nature,
trying to figure out how to make that color look like that color on this piece
of paper.
Um,
the challenges are there always,
but the,
um,
the kind of eye opening aspect of drawing is the thing that makes me keep
wanting to do.
I do it every day,
um,
for at least some chunk of the day.
And when the deadline is getting closer and closer,
I'm,
I'm drawing,
you know,
day and half the night,
uh,
as I will be for the next few months and it will lose some of its joy by the
time we hit January.
I know that because I've done it before,
but at the end I look back on it and I feel connected to the information in the
book because of the way I have absorbed it and interpreted it and ultimately
presented it.
Hi.
Uh,
one of the big differences between 1988 and now it's sort of the spread of the
Internet,
that growth of the Internet,
especially particularly thinking about Wikipedia and things like that.
Um,
and one of the downsides of those is they,
they lack a lot of the curation,
uh,
and the simplification.
And it was just wondering what your thoughts were on like the universal
accessibility of things like Wikipedia in your pocket as opposed to the way that
you approached this book or did you find yourself trying to use that in creating
the new edition of the book or did you find that you rather go to more
traditional sources?
No,
no.
I would be crazy not to use it.
I mean it's an extraordinary tool.
And it,
it's interesting because why has this book still in print after,
after 30,
almost 30 years when the Internet is,
um,
has all this information,
it has all the facts,
but it doesn't make me care about them.
I simply know it's a terrific resource and I can look things up and I can find
things and I can keep finding layers of things depending on what level of
information I want.
But at the end of the day,
I have to interpret what I've learned.
And that's what I said earlier about being an editor.
I have to decide what it is in this book with it's limited,
you know,
format we can actually say and make clear.
My goal is to,
is to encourage curiosity in a way that would perhaps nudge you to the internet
or some other source of information for more detail,
but you would feel excited about it enough to do that.
Um,
the difference between facts and information presented through basically what
seems like one voice visually,
verbally.
It's,
I mean,
all our work all comes together to create that book.
So it's a single voice.
You're not seeing different things designed in different ways.
You're not seeing ads,
you're not seeing any of that sort of stuff.
No distractions.
Just look at the page and stir an interest in the,
in the,
in the information,
not expecting to answer all the questions about it,
not even attempting to,
but sturdy interest in,
star that curiosity and then go for it.
Use the rest of the,
the world as your and,
and all those other tools as your encyclopedia.
All right.
Thanks.
Thanks very much.
[inaudible].